sans ces partis qui ont aperçu en jambes
bien des ponts je vous aime beaucoup
vous savez ça faisait pas partie d'un
ensemble c'est parti je vous aime
beaucoup mais je suis content de se voir
pour regarder les jeux de 20 heures
dans les faits devant les jeux en
général vous participez parfois la voix
j'étais chez ma mère on a mangé ils vont
regarder après les jeux le chercher
maman chez malgré vous à vous habitez
paris
j'habite paris tout à paris même pari de
même on sait que le bio dans paris et
actuellement on circule bilan nom pareil
ça va c'est cool tu veux pas me répéter
je ne répèterai plus jamais tu ne te
promets je le promets tu prends qu'il
s'appelle va réussir
je suis tout à fait à répéter toile
vidéo mais jamais je rappelle quand même
été avec des copains mais la fouine je
te jure que non
on n'a perdu qu'à madame s'il est
tellement dans le jeu qui ne veut pas
revenir
il a pris ce cache cache très à coeur
car adams du rhin dans les gars je vous
le dis ah oui là ouais c'est sûr y'a
qu'à mi combat qui me regarde sous des
draps juste là on démarre à tartu
démarquant là le tournage de l'est
[Applaudissements]
non parce qu'ils demandent quand tu
démarres le tournoi on va la faire ces
messieurs juste l'excusé pas ils n'ont
qu'à valable mais lyon 4 en fait j'étais
en boîte effectivement aux états unis et
j'étais avec un ami à moi qui est un
célèbre street artist la bac c'est pas
de mr brainwash et qui a accès un peu à
toutes les stars ouais je vois le genre
tu vois ce gars il est très sympa ce mec
sain français et donc j'étais en boîte
avec lui et il ya de justin bieber
rihanna une table évidemment avec douze
mille gardes du corps et évidemment lui
va moi je suis juste derrière les gardes
du corps c'est vraiment comme ça que moi
moi moi donc ça dure 35 minutes au bout
35 minutes tu dois lui lui ça mon pote
et je rentre et en fait quand je suis là
je sais pas trop quoi leur dire tu vois
un peu gênant donc je parle vite fait
avec avec bieber kim qui me dit justin
bieber way qui me dit en gros en gros il
me dit écoute ce que nous ici on parle
qu'avec bébé me dit écoute il faut que
tu crois en jésus tu crois en jésus tu
aura pas de problème ça c'est le message
qu'il n'a pas tort mais ce qui était
marrant c'est avec le verre le truc
l'ambiance sur havas de à base de ça on
a le colisée si tu crois en jésus et y
aller rihanna qui était là avec une pote
avec une amie à elle et elle danse en
grande pompe en quoi tu vois ce que le
diable et moi je me chauffe g ok on
danse on n'est pas beaucoup à la trappe
un peu derrière elle ouais mais
attention en distance parce qu'on vient
vous avez multiplié vos conquêtes
avant d'être connu après un par l'infini
puisque avant il y avait rien du tout à
zéro
ah ouais ya là aussi très jeune en plus
j'étais jeune et j'avais les problèmes
qui est un jeune peut connaître donc
c'est ça oui d'acné âge avait plus que
de la cne monde ont cherché ma peau
mais tu vas y ma mère m'avait raconté un
truc raconté un truc intermat au top et
ma mère l'emmène chez le dermato c'est
une vraie story elle vous emmène chez le
dermato et le dr matin me regarde et
c'est la première phrase il me dit
écoute et je vous promets que vous
n'aurez plus de boutons à partir de
maintenant je dis mais comment pouvoir
l'être sur une diva ya plus de place du
coup on a discuté
j'ai pas une minute trente j'étais bien
alcoolisé et je lui ai dit écoute moi je
sais que j'ai aucune chance avec toi si
tu as envie d'un mec ce soir d'un mec
facile je suis un mec facile non tu
prends tu me prends tu fais ce que tu
veux de moi et elle m'a fait et elle est
partie non stop
est-ce qu il connaît votre numéro de
téléphone parker qui rêvent d'un grave
je pense ouais bah oui ouais ouais faut
que je dise oui non non
je peux le dire c'est fini
06 34 non 16 tonnes
voilà ces numéros cyril hanouna
messieurs dames appelait le bâtard
franchement il y aura sa sommes déjà
non mais sans déconner alors vous donner
le numéro de catalogue riche
gk c'est en effet relevé lui nico alors
atteint son attention
alors attention on est calme mais on est
calme 06 14
c'est évident
kelly 97 98 ça rigolait les mecs ça
vraiment je vous kiffe genou qui c'est
mon vrai numéro 0 6 3 de l'avenue earth
et 16
franchement non c'est mon vrai numéro
arrête c'est comme toi ton numéro sebha
98 33